now well skyrocketing inflation means
costs are being passed down to just
about everyone more businesses are
feeding the pinch even big online
retailers yeah and now the biggest one
of them all is adding new fees john
langler takes a closer look
earlier
not
and it's like available basically two
weeks notice amazon will now add a five
percent fuel and inflation surcharge to
third-party sellers in the u.s that use
their fulfillment services maxim
cornulov owns organo republic the
florida e-commerce seed seller's been
selling products on amazon since 2016.
his company will be affected by the new
fee it goes into effect april 28th
the amazon it's a great opportunity
and it's a lot of potential but every
year
i think it's getting harder and harder
in a letter to sellers amazon says it's
been able to absorb cost increases in
the past but the constant change in
inflation has led to the new charge it's
so like you've been wrapped constantly
because they are increasing their fees
all the time under the different excuse
corneloff says he's pivoting to more
website promotions outside of amazon
he's encouraging his consumers to check
companies direct sites for products
prices can be a lot lower than you
ordered the same product from amazon and
probably it will be the case even more
and more because they keep
changing their fees john langley live
local now